do you think Trump should have been
removed
from Twitter
should his account be restored uh his
account should be restored and this is
coming from somebody who really dislikes
an enormous number of Donald Trump's
tweets um again he's a very important
political personage
even if he weren't I don't think that he
should be banned from from Twitter or
Facebook in coordinated fashion
by the way I hope that opinion about
people who I think are far worse than
Donald Trump right people I everyone
knows I'm not an Alex Jones guy I don't
like Alex Jones I think Alex Jones oh I
think Alex should be back on Twitter I
do actually because I think that there
are plenty of people who are willing to
say that what he's saying is wrong and
I'm not a big fan of this idea that that
because people I disagree with and
people who have personally targeted me
by the way I mean Alex Jones has been
has said some some things about me
personally that I'm not real fond of but
you guys not well we're not besties now
it turns out yeah you know all I've said
is I don't really enjoy a show he said
some other stuff about the Antichrist
and such but that that's that's a bit of
a different thing I suppose you know
even so yeah you know I'm I'm just not a
big fan of this idea like I've defended
people who have really gone after me on
a personal level I've targeted me that
so the Town Square is online
Banning people from the Town Square is
unpersoning them unless you violated a
criminal statute you should not be
unpersoned in American society as a
general rule that doesn't mean that
companies that are not platforms don't
have the ability to respond to you I
think
Adidas is right to terminate his
contract with Kanye for example with yay
um you know that's but
twittering Adidas
so the way your stance on free speech to
the degree it's possible to achieve on a
platform like Twitter is you fight bad
speech with more speech with better
speech
and that's
um so if Alex Jones and Trump was
allowed back on
in in the coming months and years
leading up to the 2024 election you
think that's going to make for a better
world in the long term I think that on
the principle that people should be
allowed to do this and the alternative
being a group of thought bosses telling
us what we can and cannot see yes so I
think in the short term it's going to
mean a lot of things that I I don't like
very much sure I mean that's sometimes
the cost of doing business you know like
I think that one of the one of the costs
of freedom is people doing things that I
don't particularly like and I would
prefer the freedom with with all the
with all the stuff I don't like than not
the freedom